[Music]
hey you guys it's the first tomes of
terror of 2021
so let's get right into it how i ended
up reading this particular book
was that the author himself evan b
whitmer
sent me an email and asked me if i would
like
a free copy of this book to read and
review on the channel
so of course i said sure it sounded
really cool he said he's like a
surrealist
writer and it was kind of like a short
story collection which i like
so i was like sure send me an e-book
copy so i got an e-book copy
um which is why i don't have the cover
i'll just like put it
over here at some point there it is look
the magic of editing
so this book is really
interesting now i have to say like i
enjoyed the hell out of this book okay
it's like
it's like a short story collection but
it's almost structured more like a
horror anthology film
in the sense that there's like a frame
story and then there's the other
stories that are kind of like within the
frame and it's sort of
laid out like that now i can't there's
two things that i'll
that are negatives and i'll get that out
of the way first um
and that's and it's just mostly like
little [ __ ] the cover design
uh as you could see is really not
um ideal i mean it looked like
you know it just looks like somebody did
it with like a piece of clip art in like
five minutes or whatever
okay i'm a graphic designer so i'm gonna
be picky about that kind of [ __ ] so i
really don't like the cover
um and the interior there was a lot of
typos not well not necessarily typos but
like stuff
at the beginning of sentences like
wasn't uh capitalized when it was
supposed to be it's like you know there
was
just like little weird things like that
like little apostrophes and
commas and stuff out of place the book
came out the first time
in december of 2019 i believe now when
you look on the amazon page for the book
now
it says that it's been re-edited by like
a professional editor as of september
2020
so i'm not really sure if you know i got
an old one that wasn't re-edited like it
it wasn't
super it wasn't super distracting but
there were kind of like a lot of where i
was just kind of like oh you know that
should be capitalized or
there shouldn't be a comma there there
should be a comma there that's just that
kind of stuff
um and like i said i'm a writer too and
i also like edit my own work and
you know so i'm really kind of uh anal
attentive about that kind of stuff
but uh those are really the only two
negatives that i have about the book so
like i said i just wanted to get that
out of the way
first just because you know i don't like
to i don't like being negative i don't
like being negative about books
so basically the premise of this and
it's like i'm not even really sure
this is multi-genre it's basically the
guy
evan whitmer i'm from what i could
determine this might be his first book i
think he like wrote a lot of um he has a
website called oddfiction.com
and uh he's the webmaster of that and he
uh
posts a lot of his stories on there so
i'm assuming that
you know maybe some of these stories
came from that site or whatever but this
seems to be like his first
uh published book the genre but like i
said some of the stories are horror some
of them
are funny some of them are like
dark fantasy almost or like satire
you know black comedy uh that type of
stuff so it's really really hard to
say exactly what genre this is because
it's kind of
it kind of like spans a lot of different
genres i will say that a lot of the
stories have like a really good
a really good sense of humor about them
like i really really liked the humor in
a lot of the stories it's very
sharp it's very it's it's like a
surrealist
kind of humor sort of and it's like i
really dug that so that was something
that was kind of a thread that went
through like a lot of the stories
and um that was one thing that i really
enjoyed about this is like some of the
[ __ ] was like really really funny
so basically let me see if i can explain
this in a way because this is a weird
book and i'm saying that like in the
best
possible way because i love weird [ __ ]
you guys know like i'm really into
surrealism and all that kind of stuff
so this was kind of like right in my
wheelhouse so
first we have the frame story
now this is called pages from the pizza
crows so the frame story is
in the first person so you can imagine
that this is the author talking directly
to you
and talking excuse me talking about this
strange thing that is happening to him
what begins to happen is that a crow
starts coming to his window and like
sitting on his windowsill
now at first the crow is bringing him
things
like objects and he starts to slowly
discover
that every time this crow comes back
like if he gives the crow something
a little piece of food or an inanimate
object
the crow will bring him something back
like as a trade
okay so this kind of goes on for a while
you know just every now and then he
brings like other things just like
random [ __ ]
but one day he leaves out some pizza the
author leaves out some pizza
and the crow eats some pizza and after
that happens the crow starts bringing
him
pages that have stories written on them
so that's kind of like the opening
frame and then he's like here's the
first story that i got from the crow
like after the first time they ate pizza
and then as it goes on like throughout
the
book he starts to discover that
the kind of pizza that it is determines
what
type of story the chrome brings so it's
like what a different toppings different
crust styles
um you know different whether it was hot
or cold so he starts to like experiment
with giving this crow like different
types of pizza
to see what kind of stories the crow
will bring
and intermittently throughout the book
there's little like interstitials that's
called you know pizza crow
five pizza crow six whatever and you
know he'll
be talking like the author will be
talking about how the experimentation is
going and this is the kind of pizza that
i gave
the bird this day and this is the story
that i got for that so it's kind of like
just keeps popping in like that so like
i said that's why it's kind of more like
an anthology movie in that way because
it has
this continuous frame story that's going
through the whole thing so
the stories in there are really kind of
otherwise unrelated and i really like
it was kind of like a great concept
because
you can take a bunch of real disparate
types of stories and tie them all
together
in this fashion because you know this is
a crow he's bringing these random
stories
and the thing that you trade him for
like you know makes the story
different so you can get away with a lot
of different styles
all the stories are odd because it you
know it's
it's surrealist fiction but it's not so
far out there
that you know people are gonna be like
what the [ __ ] you know is
does that mean or anything like that
they're still like pretty
straightforward stories but they're just
like
strange you know i mean they have like
surrealist aspects to them
and to demonstrate that i'll kind of go
through and tell you about each of the
stories and you know tell you which one
was my favorite and all that other kind
of stuff
so basically the first one uh which i
really liked is called
bedfellows now this is about a
couple who have broken up like they're
still friends but you know they broke up
a while back and i guess like
the the woman has like another boyfriend
now or whatever
but they have this strange supernatural
curse i guess you would call it that
they can't be asleep at the same time
if they are asleep at the same time then
one of them will transport into the
other one's bed
like physically you know and they said
when they were together it worked out
pretty good because you know one of them
worked night shift one of them worked
day shifts so they were never sleeping
at the same time
but now that they've broken up and uh
the woman is thinking about moving to
japan
and they're worried that you know if she
falls asleep there and like the time
difference and everything and like what
if i fall asleep in japan and then like
you fall asleep at the same time
and then you'll transport yourself all
the way to japan and then you have to
like get back to your house it's like
you won't be able to afford it
so yeah so that's kind of like the first
story so this is the type of
uh story that we're talking about it's
kind of like these kind of surrealist
conceits and you know it kind of going
on from there like what happens with
when you're in that type of
situation in that type have that type of
curse and you've broken up and you want
to kind of live your own lives
but you can't really do that because
you're constantly in danger of being
teleported somewhere else
you know if somebody falls asleep at the
same time as you
so that was the first story the second
one
is called uh boligami and basically that
one starts out
with a dude and he wakes up in the
morning
and he notices that his wife who was
sleeping in bed next to him obviously
is gone and in her place is a pink
metal scalpel and so he goes around the
house like looking for her
and then he slowly starts to determine
that there's something really weird
going on in the neighborhood where
all of the dudes are coming out of the
house
their houses like with different weapons
and like some of them are made out of
pink metal
and they basically end up having to like
it's like a battle royale type of thing
they they have to like fight each other
and i'm not gonna say why like or how it
resolves itself or anything but that was
like a really good one too it was like
super violent
and like i said all of these are kind of
funny but like in a weird
they're all they give me kind of like a
twilight zone kind of vibe actually
because just these
these creepy weird setups
and then with this kind of dark humor
like under
you know kind of underpinning all of it
and i really really like
i just really liked the tone of a lot of
the stories like i said i like some of
them better than others obviously that i
mean that's always going to happen in an
anthology type thing like this
but i mean i just really really dug the
whole tone of this
like the humor of it really like hit
home for me i think so i really really
like that about it so the second one
polygamy is kind of like a um
you know battle royale type thing with
all these dudes having to fight each
other you don't really find out why
until later
then there's one called captured by
animals
now this one i really liked this one was
like really kind of sweet
it's about someone it's written in first
person and it's about someone who
spies on people at campgrounds to get
realistic sounding dialogue for their
romance stories that they write and then
you find out
that this that the this author that's
writing these romance stories and is
spying on people in campgrounds
is a bear he's like a talking bear
and he's like a romance novelist and
he's writing all this
he's trying to write all this stuff and
get this realistic human dialogue
and uh he has an agent and the agent
doesn't know he's a bear and all this
other kind of stuff so it's
that one's really really cute i liked
that one very much as well then you have
one called
the red constellation now this one is
about a woman
who is kind of a shut-in because
i guess her mom and her grandmother um
warned her all the time about
men attacking them and they had both
been attacked by men at various times in
the past
so she's kind of um afraid to go out and
put herself out there so she's kind of
shy
but when she goes off to college she
decides you know hey i'm going to be
more outgoing and so her group of
friends like take her out to
um to a bar they go like bar hopping one
night or whatever
and she's having a good time but then
when they're going to this
second bar like from the first one she
sees this very distinct
red beam of light like shining down
from the sky and in and on to the club
and nobody else sees it but her
and um this freaks her out very much as
it would
and then this one goes and i don't
really want to spoil this one either but
there's a reason why that red light is
there
and it's crazy i mean you know it's like
um this one is almost kind of like
cosmic horror you know what i mean like
it kind of goes in that way with like
you know
gods and stars and all that kind of
stuff something to do with her having a
particular
kind of curse i guess you could call it
as well um so yeah this one was also
really good and then there's one called
young adult
series simulator this one is weird
because
this one is like a story inside a story
and
as i said this is already like an
anthology inside a frame story but this
is a story
inside a story basically this story is
told from the point of view of someone
who is waiting for their date i guess
there have they
they set up a date online on you know
tinder or whatever
and they're waiting at the coffee shop
for their date to show up
like this is their first date and while
they're at this
coffee shop in this bookstore they start
reading
this why a series which is like
i guess it's supposed to be like all the
rage or something so and he's like oh
i hear so much about it maybe i should
start reading it so he kind of opens it
while he's waiting for this girl to show
up
and so then so you have that frame story
and then inside it
is like it's almost like a parody of a
young adult
like fantasy series where there's these
characters they're like brothers and
they're being like pursued by weather
gods and stuff like that it reminded me
of like um
you know the lightning thief with that
percy whatever that
uh with the olympians and all that right
i haven't read them i just i just know
that the that that's like a big thing
so it almost kind of struck me as a
parody of that i this one was probably i
don't know if this was my least favorite
just because
i don't know i don't want to say that
because it's like they're all good like
all the stories are good in their own
way
this one i think was kind of like harder
for me to follow because it kept
you know going back and forth from the
person waiting and you know in the
coffee shop and
reading the book and then it would come
out and that he'd be talking to somebody
else about the book and you know all
this other stuff
but it did get like funnier like as it
went on and i thought it was like a
pretty spot-on
like parody of some of these white stuff
i don't read a lot of way fantasy
um but i know enough about the genre to
get the humor of parodying it in this
fashion so uh yeah that was like a
pretty cool concept also
then there's one called f1 which is
about
i'm not entirely sure why it's called
that actually now that i'm thinking
about it but this one was about a farmer
who has a broken down old horse named
barfly who is
deaf in one ear and blind in one eye and
old
and the farmer is thinking about putting
poor barfly out of her misery
because you know his farm he's like a
carrot farmer
and he's like you know he doesn't have
enough money to feed her anymore she's
like another mouth to feed
and blah blah but then um
somebody breaks into the
stable where the horse is kept and when
he goes in there he discovers that
her sight and hearing have returned and
also that she is pregnant
and she's real pregnant even though she
hadn't been pregnant like
a day earlier so barfly gives birth
to i don't know should i spoil it i
don't want to spoil it she yeah she
gives birth to something
and um it's not that crazy but you know
what i mean
but i don't want to spoil it so then it
kind of like goes on from there that
one's like pretty pretty short
but uh yeah that one was kind of amusing
as well and next up
i think oh hard to pick this might be my
favorite story in the collection
this is called nine tenths an ape
and it's about this anthropologist dies
and in his will he leaves to his friend
and colleague
this thing that he discovered i can't
remember where he discovered borneo or
somewhere like that i don't know he was
on like some kind of expedition
and he discovered this mummified ape
in the jungle that apparently some of
the other monkeys and apes in the jungle
had been kind of
worshiping sort of like it had been
there for like 200 years it's this
mummified ape
the apes named lefty because the the ape
is
intact except for its left hand is gone
so the guy ends up so this colleague of
the of the anthropologist that died who
was also an anthropologist
he ends up with lefty and he uh slowly
starts to discover
that this is basically like if you guys
have read the classic story i mean i
think probably everybody's read it
because we i mean we had to
read it in school uh the monkey pop
monkey's paw by ww jacobs
it's like that but in reverse because
because the ape you know the only thing
it doesn't have
is its hand is its paw so basically
whatever you wish for
it will do the opposite you know what i
mean so you
so you have to like and then like the
[ __ ] that
it's him and like this other um this
girl
who was uh like a graduate student i
guess of the guy
and so the two of them like figure out
you know that this thing grants wishes
but
whatever you wish for it does the
opposite like in a really weird way
so it's almost kind of like monkey's paw
in reverse and i think that's how it's
described in the uh
you know the description of the book
that's on amazon so it's really really
funny all the [ __ ] that they have to
come up with and like some of the [ __ ]
that happens is like crazy [ __ ] like
people coming back from the dead and
like
it's like insane insane stuff and
how they have to word everything and
then think about
the opposite you know what i mean like
for example so it's almost kind of like
if you
wish for something it will give you like
everything but that
you know what i mean so yeah so some
crazy [ __ ] happens in this story so this
was like really really funny
this might be this one and the last
story i think are
competing for my favorite one because
this one was just a riot and i
like i had a blast with it then there's
one called leafy
which is we it gave me like a weird
mid-summer type of vibe because it's
almost kind of like this weird
town or this weird community it doesn't
really say like where it is or anything
but there's all these people live there
and they have just this weird
code and these kind of strange beliefs
that are sort of religious
and it comes to pass that the main
character
realizes he's a kid but he realizes he
can't remember anything that happened in
his life before he was 10 years old
and he doesn't find this strange at
first
but then his parents like start to freak
out about like they start to quiz him
about it and he doesn't remember
anything like from when he was 10 onward
and
they apparently come up with um a reason
for why that should be
which again i will not spoil like what
the reason is why he doesn't remember
anything from before he was 10.
but yeah so that was pretty cool too
that was like kind of a weird
culty kind of one you know what i mean
so that was kind of cool too
then there's one called the bright idea
room which is basically
it's kind of like a dude wakes up in a
room
that's dark and all that's in there is
like a red lamp
and then there's another dude in the
room suddenly
and then there's a green lamp and it's
kind of like one of those stories where
because i know there's been like a lot
of stories in movies like this where
people just kind of
it's almost kind of like this
purgatorial scenario where
they just wake up in this empty room and
they can't figure out
where they are why they've been put
there who put them there
um you know if there's some connection
between them and [ __ ] like that so it
has something to do with
the lamps controlling who has whose
memories
you know what i mean if that makes any
sense okay so that's what that one is
about
that one reminded me very much of i
think was it a twilight zone episode or
something like that where
the uh were those five characters or
whatever and they just like woke up in
this room it kind of reminded me a
little bit of that
but with the elements of identity
switching
sort of i you know i don't that's not
exactly right but
you know it was close enough you know
what you know and then the last story
this one like i said the nine tenths and
eight the one about the like the monkeys
paw one
that was one of my favorites and then
this one which is the last story called
satan spies
i really really dug this one as well
this one is basically about
a guy he's staying at this motel
he has like a job interview the next day
and he's staying in a motel and he
decides
hey you know i've been working really
hard like to try to get this job because
i'm going to go and you know
party because he doesn't usually do that
type of thing so he goes out
uh to a bar and he meets these guys who
are like
all in suits and he starts hanging out
with them like they're
i'm well i think they're at the same
hotel as him and they're kind of having
a party in their room
so he just kind of goes and invites
himself and goes and has a beer or
whatever
and then they start going bar hopping
and i guess because the story is called
satan spies
i suppose it's not really a spoiler to
say that
these guys there are five of them and
they are basically satan's emissaries
and their
job is to go around and
witness people's sins
like they have to see them apparently or
the people will get away with it and the
funny thing about it is that
this story posits that hell
uh has several of these types of
emissaries like walking around on earth
and they're all in different divisions
like depending on what sin they're
witnessing like you got your serial
killer
squad you got your gambler squad you got
to sew
but they have to see it happen so they
just go
like satan sends them texts like on
their cell phone
like where a certain thing is gonna
happen that has to do with their um
with the thing that they're supposed to
be the sin that they're supposed to be
witnessing
and they have to go there and just like
look at it you know what i mean
so this regular guy that just kind of
stumbled into their uh hotel part or
their motel party or whatever
and then ended up going bar hopping with
them into strip clubs and whatnot
he ends up kind of getting involved
because
he [ __ ] up one of their witnessing jobs
which means that someone um might get
away with like
not going to hell because
none of them witnessed the thing that
happened so he has to kind of go and fix
it
this was a great story i really really
liked this story a lot like i said this
one in the monkey's paw one
that's kind of neck and neck for my
favorite ones they're all good and they
all have um
a lot to recommend them but i think
those two are probably
my favorite like i said other than some
issues with
uh you know typos just you know
capitalization like some things not
being
um you know formatted correctly stuff
like that which is
a tiny bit distracting because like i
said i'm anal attentive about that kind
of stuff but other than that this was
actually really really
well written the stories are great
there's there's like a great flow
and i just love i love the concept of it
and i love
that you get so many different genres
and but it still kind of stands together
as a coherent whole because of the frame
story
um you know about the crows and the
pizza and everything and like the
different experimentation
so i thought that was like a really um a
really wise move
to take these sort of disparate stories
like that and then put them all into one
package
and then kind of relate them to one
another through that story so i thought
that was a really really cool idea
but yeah i mean i really enjoyed the
hell out of this book um
i guess this uh according to his little
picture on the
on his amazon author page he looks real
young uh apparently he's from
pennsylvania he has a
rabbit named goblin and uh he said i
used to be a rapper on soundcloud or
something like that like in a previous
life i don't know
but there's not like a huge amount of uh
information about him but yeah this was
uh so like i said he sent me an email so
he uh sent me a
free copy of this book but that doesn't
mean that like you know that i
wouldn't say if i didn't like it but i
actually did really like it i love
surrealisaur if you like
if you like that type of thing if you
like twilight zone type of [ __ ] if you
like like dark
humor um just weird odd kind of fiction
then you will probably really dig this
and i think more people should
read it i will say it does need a cover
redesign though because the cover is
um kind of ugly but you know what are
you going to do uh so yeah that'll do it
for
this installment of tomes of terror hope
your
2021 is going well so far and i'll see
you guys on the next one
bye